Well, we don't have to break this problem into two parts,
but I'm going to. I prefer to do it that way.
So let's see how long it takes the ball to reach the top of it's trajectory.
I'm going to use this equation and I know at the top of the trajectory the final velocity is zero
where the initial velocity is up at 20 m/s and the acceleration is negative.
Remember if we've chosen V₀ to be positive and that's upwards,
acceleration which is downwards must be negative.
So that's time of 2s to go upwards and look at the top of its trajectory
it's for that instant not moving and it has to fall all the way down to the ground.
But how far does it have to fall when not just the 57 m from the top of the tower
to the ground also whatever distance it's gained on its trip upwards.
Let's calculate that--to make this extra distance calculation, I'm going to use this equation,
and it turns out that it has gone an extra distance of 20 m and notice that
I've used the time 2 because that's what we just calculated.
With this extra distance of 20 m added to this 57 m, we have a total fall distance of 77 m,
and this is the tool for the job there to calculate how much time it's going to take
and the time to fall down is 3.9 seconds.
And noticed than in solving this equation I've called the acceleration
positive again and that's because I've called Δx positive.
I could have called Δy negative since it is moving downwards, but when
possible I like to just work with positive numbers, but this is totally a matter of preference.
So we have 3.9 seconds plus our original 2 gives us a total of 5.9 seconds
that the ball will stay in the air--good work.